hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play cry of fear
the stairway now this is actually I
think there's actually one of the
original custom campaigns that I kind of
overlooked but apparently it's really
good so I'm gonna give it a try here huh
Boop on medium you all know how much I
love cry fear so I'm not even gonna
expound on my feelings towards the game
I'm just excited to get back into it
hello Simon chapter one where are you
are you sure that's not where am i oh
hello thank you thank you
lantern thank you okay okay okay I
didn't know that this one was meant for
PewDiePie my apologies I'm gonna play it
anyway okay so we got the flashlight if
I robes okay
can I get down the flashlight yeah and
then that and I think I'll need the
lantern the flashlights much better
anyway
okay so just gotta get through here
maybe a colander okay yeah thank you
wait hang on what is this oh oh yeah I
forgot they apparently threw out the
main campaign there were a bunch of
different places for different
sweatshirts that Simon could wear you
know that represent different levels are
crazy not really but okay
I like the music this doesn't look good
okay point of no return
oh hey what the hell
Jesus stop on get out of here holy balls
hahahahahaha all right then starting off
with a bang are we got the special super
awesome gun here really loud music holy
crap
okay it's pretty well lit I'm guessing
holy crap I was looking back and
expecting there to be a solid wall I
didn't know that those gonna be a
chainsaw man dashing to kill my
nevermind all right whatever
ah okay basement it's locked it's I hi
thank you come again
it's awfully well lit in here I don't
think that's gonna last you a nice oak
nice bathroom
this looks good uh-huh
that seems to be quite a few jump scares
in this game
good old cry of fear hey ma'am the Han
sis scuse me lady you're looking good
you leave a pine those holes in your
head from these bullets not dead yet
there we go Oh complain to someone else
it's apparently supposed to be a really
powerful gun took same amount of bullets
as I remember it taking to kill that
lady okay anything else okay
doesn't look like still locked I don't
have a key there's gotta be a key here
somewhere
what am I missing what that I didn't
even see that but I guess it was there
okay lucky click for me
finally the door's unlocked it didn't
take that long
okay disco chimes campaign is to stop it
with that
ah hi hi hi good you you son of a [ __ ]
he's just a tough [ __ ] away from me okay
yeah piece of crap three faced douche
nozzle
your ugly son of a [ __ ] always you get
that chainsaw at the toilet store okay
here we go hit dip okay just gonna walk
gingerly let's see I hear you
ah ha Wow
goodness gracious
well hello okay well okay game okay
where did that come in from there's no
door
wha all right can't go back I guess I
was expecting something else all right
let me save here okay I can record my
thoughts and experiences okay all right
and see here give me that give me that
give me that give me that give that okay
plenty of ammo for the pistol put this
here for the assault rifle Oh what's
this
wait a minute there's another door here
oh I I didn't even get another okay
whatever changed a single shot just pick
up that two and uh changed sewer what is
that supposed to mean
have a gun wah-ha-ha-ha who's out there
anybody holy crap it you guys okay
you're not that bad I can just get away
from you whoa whoa aah holy crap
good god oh what's at the hand I don't
need a Glock oh my god did someone just
pass through here um yeah about that
there cool hello what are you I don't
remember seeing you in anything one shot
one kill
how about you do shot 2 shot 2 kill
hi good name oh thank you hey hey buddy
that's gonna you stand right there pup
okay
oh no oh oh I reloaded you waste your
ammo if you're reloading your clips
non-empty I could taking the time to
carefully go through aha I see you in
there I see all of you I see you too
I just got to get passed on and get to
the door ah Wow okay just got to get
past and got to get past and got to get
past them till the door I have the
greatest I am the greatest ever would oh
hi why hey where'd you come from
ah where you coming guys us solve work I
don't want to fight the Tsar
you son of a [ __ ] I do not like you how
about you going ah how about
oh I actually can kill him for once
that's lovely
I like that idea this to me he's kind of
an [ __ ]
it serves to get shot to death yes I've
never actually killed him before I
didn't even know you could cry you can't
in the real game haha is convenient I
don't have a Glock anymore music you
need to calm down boss is dead music oh
I could have spent safe in here okay
carrying on the reason I'm not hitting
those Stefano's tattoos is because you
know I'm not uh those are meant for me
Oh what the hell we're done what are you
doing why are those there ah maybe the
who mo mo mo mo mo mo more Glock max I
don't ah that's better P three four five
HUP HUP there we go epic Crouch jumping
ah I forgot the key on the right side oh
okay
ah okay and I never up for that key I
don't even a knife here there we go
pick that up you are big and dumb and I
do not like you and I do not know how to
uh uh uh uh uh uh I got to be quick
about this Oh God
let's use ki ha gotta get up in the
flight I can't say ah God
get away get away you know why get away
get away
book faces douche-nozzles McGillicutty
mother hover chapter three time to end
this good golly I didn't even know we
really started it just been kinda from
the beginning and kinda a little bit
intense
see we're boughs is this a sewer boss or
was that the sewer boss made our do that
okay so it's a door here Pfeiffer yeah
more clothes changing which I do not
have because I lost my save of the
campaign I did remember finding some
t-shirts in the actual campaign I need
to heal myself I'm probably gonna die if
I don't right let's quickly what is that
clock I don't have a Glock but I'll get
a Glock if if I can get a light on my
pistol holy balls gay huh apparently
that was somewhere in the main campaign
but I never got it yeah stick to I don't
need a stick thank you very much alright
let's see first who's this huh new super
juice okay get that oh wait I had more I
didn't know that I had more to that okay
um well so I got the thing on the Glock
I don't really need the flashlight do I
alright see combined oh look at that
that thing is bright and I can finally
sight down without doing anything else
is phenomenal this is great I never had
this before it was probably hidden away
in a really obvious place I could have
found it a long time ago but I did not
because I'm an idiot as we have already
covered in many play throughs of mine I
am dumb but I'm good at doom I like the
music
kinda what is that what is that it's a
cat a dead cat why is our dead cat here
which way do I go uh curiosity killed
the cat Black Cat crossed my path what
are you trying to tell me here
okay what is this what is this a
newspaper there's a phone over there I
don't think I want it wait isn't this
the same five four three two one four
five four three two one
four
I don't think that did oh hello no thank
you
what the [ __ ] are you talking about I
need help please
five two four seven five two four seven
there's something at the other end of
that Hall
you'll not to the light which would be
that way five four two five two four
seven five four two seven are now five
two four seven Oh God
okay house right no need to panic I got
it okay let me get my Glock out again oh
wait I don't have the Glock tactical
light five three four seven nothing all
right then I don't know why there isn't
a tactical light for the assault rifle
that seems like the most likely
candidate to have it all so I can pistol
whip now not that I have any reason to
no say boy ah [ __ ] you good god I
thought there was something wrong with
that wooden structure there was
something very wrong huh I heard that
yeah okay back to the craziness Oh rifle
rounds
I don't really have the space of the
patients for the shotgun
I suppose I could drop the other handgun
but no real need to I just reload here
plenty of ammo for this sure which I had
a light though no light all right Glock
it is there we go
I heard Saha ah
that was probably a waste of ammo but
super effective I know tech dot haha
okay so those those people those people
are wimps ah hello never sat down up
banging boom hey boom huh okay boom oh
there we go
got you hello whoa you're quick
jeez slow down there zippy oh the son of
a [ __ ] you stay there ah okay
one more down how many more are there oh
you [ __ ] I got out here okay if I
actually hit my target it's probably
gonna be a lot more effective than
spraying prey
oh you [ __ ] hurt come on suck that
down man they heard me good ah okay I
don't have enough ammo for all of you
I do not ha God bad timing bad timing
bad timing bad timing bad timing
ah ha ha ha hi
what guy hi I love you Sophie
hi
wait what that my health got extend no
my health what my health did not get
extended my health got unstandardized
I didn't mean to take the bills I
thought they were gonna help a bollocks
I do not know what's going on in this in
this custom campaign I am lost I am
thoroughly lost all right gone out for
it again oh hi Sophie how you doing
you're good all right I'll be back for
you up later
uh eventually leave you here in the blue
oh goody I love the chalk outline shadow
world that's regular Simon I'm evil
Simon hi hi buddy hi wave waving out eh
what else oh no no no no no no no no no
give me give me the pills give me the
pill
Jesus hi stop it I don't have enough
fell for you oh okay I need to use up I
need to need to use a much better gun or
I ignore them completely ignore them and
I climb the ladder that's what I should
do
yes most definitely or I should shoot
simon up there no that would be a bad
choice I don't need to kill myself
that's suicide the real choice is to
face my demons head on apply directly to
the forehead
maybe shoot those pin Oh a man aiming
would be good oh oh I didn't heal myself
that's right I healed oh I'm an idiot I
have to take those pills why did I have
to take those pills and imma save after
I take this coop and then I'm gonna go
back in there I'm onna get des I'm all
get down although they are kind of tough
I mean really they are but I just got to
be patient with my shots nice and
distributed maybe if I could find a way
to get up there and then I could use my
height to my advantage we'll see but
then I'll be right up in them with their
shotguns and that probably wouldn't work
out too well let's try it anyway cuz I'm
a fool to myself huh go go go go go go
up up up up up you go keep going keep
going yeah
hi Simon
Hey
that was it haha
I'm the greatest oh my room
oh my room oh okay woo ha oh so nice
ahh my half-life Foster God love you
Gordon Freeman this seems familiar blood
in the shower no no blood no blood it
was haunted soap I know
Bay's right weird it doesn't seem that I
can open of course it's not over yet why
would it be my health is still stunted
better take more pills
yay nice thick nice music
okay I go outside now what awaits me out
here
nobody's home how do you know you didn't
even knock anti-social nobody's home
this is this is towards the end of cry
fear I do remember this oh hello
why do I not go down the road beef used
to open this wants to open it's already
open
huh excuse ha-hi why ah [ __ ] you bu you
try and access Geyer here the garden hi
are you come out here or you wait right
there you seem to be stuck to self the
car is working
oh I get it I get it I get it I get a
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme
huh it was all Hooten dream oh good
Oh whoo okay so that was silliness give
me my pills I'll be on my way
excuse me sorry I'm hyped up on
antipsychotics and they're not working
give me Mike get me Mike get me my
thingies I'll be on my way
oh it's dark in here I hope something
doesn't jump out and attack me and there
was a Glock round or their bull is there
a gun in here somewhere whatever let's
go let's go hotel let's go hey pro dodge
and now are you stuck there are you
gonna be a dick
oh whoa whoa you kind of jumped out at
me okay you come with me and I'm gonna
go back and I'm gonna open this and I'm
gonna go around again so that they
follow me out and that way I can
actually get to the garage which would
be nice hey get out of there you [ __ ]
get out of the garage get out of the
garage
hey guess what you're a dick I'm just
gonna limp around and whack you in the
face until you realize how big of an
[ __ ] you are [ __ ] I'm gonna die again
wait am there were pills in the house I
gotta get back in the house and take the
damn pills get out my way oh no oh no no
I got boxed in you didn't see but one
guy was behind me - that's [ __ ]
stupid this is me when I'm mad
bing-bong bing-bong bing-bong bing-bong
bing-bong me what nice and lovely music
there is here well I sure do love it
here come here
we're gonna go toe to toe you dick I
ain't goes yeah there we go yeah take
another pill
oh what's that more you want more I
apologize for getting upset it's not
stupid it's just I didn't approach it
correctly if I had approached it
correctly I would not have these
problems it's not stupid the game makers
not stupid I'm not I got a little upset
thank you all right
oh there we go
da da da [ __ ] da
there we go that's the end of the custom
campaign I was literally two inches from
the end but I had to restart quite a few
times because I'm stupid
okay what the [ __ ] is going on here what
is happening to me
when I woke up I thought I was dead but
I was in my room with my computer turned
off mom and dad aren't home they must
have went out but something's not right
here who the heck is that guy with the
chainsaw why is he trying to kill me I
just have to keep going until I can find
someone who can help I hope I'm not
going insane this is this is [ __ ] just
[ __ ]
mmm I thought I killed the guy with it
well there were two guys with a chainsaw
there's a really fast guy and then
there's a really tall skinny guy with
spikes coming out of his entire body
okay other than the very ending other
than the very end the very end which I'm
assuming that the game maker thought
that no one could possibly die from that
he gave him so much health right there
on the countertop there was so much
health right there on the countertop
that there's no way anyone could die
from that they'd have to be stupid or
panic so I'm an idiot the game is not
wrong the game is actually very good I
really like the custom camping maybe a
little too much on the jump scaring
intensity no atmosphere not much
atmosphere in this custom campaign but
still it was not bad I did enjoy it and
I got an overall accuracy of 45% what's
my grade what did I get
oh you're not gonna give me a drink okay
well I did all right I did okay so thank
you everybody so much for watching click
the annotation for videos it I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye